thank you very much hello everyone as
already said I'm Robert I'm a PhD
student at to Berlin and today I'm going
to talk to you about two of my absolute
favorite topics one being evolutionary
computation and the other one being
accelerated computation and Jacks
but before we're going to get started I
quickly want to give you my philosophy
on the current take of machine learning
so many of you might know this classic
painting by Michelangelo called the
creation of Adam
and in this painting we see this magical
moment in which got an old white men is
about to instill life into Adam a young
white man and sort of the beauty of this
painting comes from basically the
silence and this magical moment that is
about to be happening
and in the machine Learning Community
where right now arguably at a similar
inflection point where there are many
people in large companies who are of the
opinion that just scaling great and
descent together with large Transformer
based models and the internet scale data
we're going to get to a point where
we're going to get to AGI
and many of them use the brain and our
own central nervous system as a
motivation for example in the form of
dopamine and reward prediction errors or
metacognition in the prefrontal cortex
and this is all nice but what if this is
only a local Optimum and what if this is
actually not going to lead to the moment
where the fingers actually touch each
other and we're going to get to AGI
and in nature basically there's only one
single process of which we know that it
has led to general intelligence in
diverse forms and this is basically
biological evolution
so what I want to do here is not bash
screen descent based learning but simply
raise awareness that we need diversity
of ideas and diversity of sort of
approaches for how to tackle this
problem
okay
so this is not supposed to be a history
lesson and instead I want to sort of
motivate large-scale black box
optimization and how Jacks and this
package that I developed evosacs can
support these so hopefully we've Now
sort of reached some excitement in terms
of this topic and going forward there's
going to be a small dip where we're
quickly going to get some some
background knowledge on on back back
blocks optimization and what an
evolutionary Optimizer is and basically
from there on I'm going to tell you why
evil sacks tackled some of the
challenges that modern black box
optimization is facing right now and
basically afterwards we're going to go
to the moon and I'm going to give you
some examples for what kind of cool
research you can do and sort of what the
future of evolutionary optimization
might be
and for anyone who's interested in the
slides or sort of the code or or the
accompanying information there's like a
tiny url url link that you can visit and
yeah
so let's get started so basically at the
start of of this talk is the definition
of what black box optimization actually
encompasses and most of you are probably
familiar with white box optimization
where we have what we assume to have
access to the underlying function f
which we are trying to minimize with
respect to the input X and that means
that we can basically calculate
well-behaved gradients through this
right so this might be for example a
neural network forward pass where we try
to optimize some form of loss with
respect to the parameters of of that
neural network
in blackbox optimization we're
essentially assuming or we're not
assuming that we have access to to this
gradient and this might come due to
different reasons this could for example
be that the function that we're trying
to optimize is inherently
non-differentiable like for example like
a spiking neural network or some form of
hard thresholding operation that we use
um or that the gradients that we're
trying to compute are actually not well
behaved for example exploding or
Vanishing
and there are many different ways how
one can go about black box optimization
including for example random search or
Basin optimization uh success of halving
or hyperband which use some form of
smart early stopping Criterion and what
I'm trying to argue today in this talk
is that evolutionary optimization sort
of is one alternative that sort of
fulfills a sweet spot we cannot only use
it for doing hyper perimeter
optimization of like 10 parameters but
we can actually also optimize small
neural networks up to a million
parameters which allows us to discover
new algorithm components and I'm going
to come back to that
good so here are a couple of examples
where you might want to do black box
optimization some of them I've already
talked about including hyper perimeter
optimization non-differentiable
operations like spiking or hard tension
neural architecture surge but it's also
useful in the context of sparse
reinforcement learning where basically
we're not doing exploration in the state
space of the agent but we're doing it in
parameter space
and finally this is something I'm again
going to come back to you using
Evolution to to essentially meta
learning and Computing gradients through
a long analog computation Maps
okay so let's rewind or go forward One
Step what is an evolution strategy and
how does it work so basically at the
core of an evolution strategy lies a
search distribution which could for
example be a multivariate gaussian with
sufficient statistics M and covariance
sigma which is here assumed to be
diagonal for example
and then based off of that search
distribution we sample solution
candidates so axes for example which we
use to minimize and we go ahead and we
evaluate some function that we're
interested in minimizing and compute
so-called Fitness course
and we do so for a population 1 to n
different candidates and based off of
these Fitness evaluations we then update
our search distribution
and intuitively this update is going to
try to
um
increase the likelihood of sampling good
or well-performing solution candidates
from that search distribution
and then we can continue to iterate this
process until we find a good solution or
a suitable solution or until our AWS or
gcp credits run out
good
so
what are challenges of modern
evolutionary optimization in principle
this sounds like something you could
Implement in plain python
um
two challenges one is one related to
sort of scaling this to latch search
spaces and this is sort of Simply due to
the inherent sort of nature of doing
random search and high dimensions and
the curse of dimensionality but another
one which I'm going to focus on today is
one which is related to the engineering
aspects of running these evolutionary
optimization processes
and oftentimes in these settings we're
interested in taking these population
members and evaluating them on tasks
which might not be super quick to run
like for example this could be in the
hyper perimeter optimization case
training an entire network or rolling
out an agent in an environment and
trying to optimize the parameters of its
policy and oftentimes we want to do this
multiple times to get a good Monte Carlo
estimate of their Fitness
and usually what people then do is
either use some form of simple
multi-processing to sort of parallelize
this Fitness evaluation or use some form
of task manager like like Ray or desk
but this ultimately requires some form
of engineering overhead where you have
to write sort of a worker node and you
have to make sure that this all runs
smoothly but maybe we can do something
which is a bit more smooth
but before we go there
this kind of limitation of the
engineering side and also the curse of
dimensionality have made one of the
grandfathers of deep learning and the
sort of question or highly
criticize the role of random search or
more specifically great and free
estimation or gradient free optimization
and what I'm trying to claim or show you
today is that Jax this new library
developed by or somewhat new library
developed by Google and might actually
make our lives a lot easier and also
might help us in finding and discovering
new evolutionary optimizers in the first
place
so what do I mean by that or what is Jax
Jax is on the top surface or when you
probably first encounter it in automatic
differentiation library but to me it's
it's much more since it allows us to
essentially be much more flexible in
terms of doing GPU programming or TPU
programming or doing accelerated
Computing in the first place
so what do I mean by that Jax comes with
a set of function Transformations at the
core being grad jit vmap and pmap and
these can be composed to either
um train a large Transformer model on
multiple devices or to do other cool
things and evolution being one of them
so let me show you what I mean by that
we already spoke about sort of this
problem of evaluating multiple
population members for multiple times to
get good Fitness estimates and now in
sort of an embarrassingly parallel way
and this would look like follows you
would have an evaluation function which
takes a seat as an input and the
parameters and returns some form of
Fitness score and then we would Loop
over the different population members
these different red points if you
remember in this cartoonish search
picture that I showed and we would
evaluate each one of them for the
different seat and then we would take
the mean of that as the fitness estimate
and sort of update our search
distribution with these candidates and
this would take long and you could do
multi-processing or array or Das but
these would all introduce some form of
communication latency
and what Jax allows us to do is
essentially take two of these Primitives
or function Transformations that I
showed before vmap and pmap and
vectorize the evaluation across random
seats and then device parallelize these
this seat or multi-seed evaluation
across the different population members
okay so here what you've done with two
lines of code is get rid of these two
nasty loops and use as many or
accelerators as you have access on your
host machine
okay
awesome great so this gets rid of this
entire engineering Hassle and allows for
high throughput Fitness evaluations with
large populations
and now Andrew's evosacs which is the
library I'm presenting to you about
today which is essentially a Jax based
library of many different evolutionary
optimization algorithms so here I'm only
showing a subset and all of these
Evolution strategies can be themselves
jitted vmapped and pmapped which means
that you can run multiple instantiations
of them basically in parallel but I'm
going to get to that
um basically the the set of algorithms
that are implemented in evosex can be
divided into three main classes one
being finite difference based gradient
estimators
um the other being estimation of
distribution Evolution strategies and
then we have genetic algorithms and any
more esga and black box algorithms and
they sort of differ in the way how they
update the search distribution and they
differ in sort of the nature of the
search distribution is it a unimodal
normal distribution node you have an
archive of solutions
okay so now let's let's take a step and
look a bit uh deeper under the hood how
does evosex work
um basically you would import from Evil
sax
um
a strategy which you would want to use
for example CMAs and then you would
instantiate that strategy with a given
population size
number of Dimensions so this is the
search space that you're looking at and
then you would initialize the strategy
State Which con which contain like the
mean or the covariance Matrix of your
search state
and then based off of that
initialization you would run then this
for Loop in which you would first ask
and Sample different candidates like the
these points here and you would evaluate
these points on the task and then based
off of these Solutions and their
evaluations you would update the search
distribution and iterate this process
and all of the strategies or optimizers
that I showed you before follow this
simple API where you initialize the
strategy you ask for candidates you
evaluate your population so this this
dot dot dot here would be where your
vmap and pmap Magic come into place and
you would update the search distribution
okay and then there are sort of some
utilities for achieving the best member
or the best fitness score obtained so
far
um next to the the standard evolutionary
optimizers that evosex is providing in
Jax we're also providing uh utilities
for for standard things you would want
to do in evolutionary optimization like
for example some of these evolutionary
optimizers might not want to use the Raw
Fitness score but they might want to use
um some transformation to reduce the
variance of sort of your updates that
you do in your search during your search
and another utility Evo sax provides is
a tool for essentially taking Pi trees
or some representation of neural network
weights and then flattening them into a
vector to do evolutionary optimization
on that vector and then reshaping again
and this is maybe one detail I haven't
spoken about but most of these
evolutionary optimizers I spoke about
before they actually sort of Discord to
a certain degree the network topology
that you would like to optimize in sort
of deep learning like settings
okay so let's come to a set of three
examples or things you could try to do
with evosacs one being
um sort of a simple parallelized
um accelerated evaluations and then
doing evolutionary optimization in the
outer loop where you're just optimizing
for example the parameters of the neural
network policies of these agents or of
these robots shown up here and here
under the hood we're using Brax which is
another
um
Google library and gymnax which is
another library of mine to do sort of
accelerated rollouts yeah and
importantly like basically evosacs
implements these 30 different optimizers
and you can use them to Benchmark
against or come up with your your own
new evolutionary method and yeah we're
planning on releasing a
separate Benchmark based on top fairly
soon so watch out for that
okay so this is basically or what I've
shown you so far is like the standard
thing where you would just use Jacks to
do parallel evaluation of Fitness
another thing which you could try to do
is take a single function which runs
black box optimization or evolutionary
optimization and then go ahead and ask
yourself hey can I actually run the same
optimization Loop just multiple times
across different random seeds or across
different hyper parameters
and with Jacks similar to how I showed
you how to parallelize single
evaluations of a function you could also
evaluate this or paralyze this entire
training Loop okay so basically you
would take this function run yes Loop
and you would simply wrap it with a V
map that sort of batches across
different Sigma Nets which is a hyper
parameter and then if you run this
function now it would basically run the
same Loop across three different
Sigma units okay and this would all be
parallelized automatically or
automatically vectorized on your
accelerator okay so you basically don't
have to do anything except for wrap it
with this vmap and supplying sort of an
array or some batch shape to to map over
and for example what I'm showing you
here is an animation where this is done
for one
evolutionary Optimizer differential
Evolution across different differential
weights and crossover raises are hyper
perimeters and you can literally see how
this optimization is done in parallel
for hundreds of evolution strategy runs
yeah and one thing you could then also
Imagine is sort of hooking up a meta
Evolution strategy to optimize these
different sort of in parallel running
Evolution strategies
good and then finally one application
I'm very excited about is sort of using
evolutionary optimization to discover
new algorithms and what we're doing here
is we have some form of Base algorithm
with parameters data which we can run in
the Inner Loop and then use evolution in
the outer loop to discover essentially
new algorithms in the Inner Loop okay so
you define some form of meta Fitness
score and then use evolution in the
outer loop to optimize the matter
parameters without having to compute
gradients through essentially the unroll
of the algorithm in the enolip
and there are already a bunch of
applications of this for example Loop
mats and Google has used this to
discover new gradient based optimizers
there's been work on discovering new
plasticity rules or reinforcement
learning objective functions and what
I'm going to quickly highlight today is
two of my own works that I've done one
being on a learning Evolution strategies
and the other one being on learning
genetic algorithms
okay so this was a project I did last
summer during an internship at deepmind
where we used sort of the evosacs
utilities to do meta black box
optimization so to parametrize a learned
Evolution strategy or an evolution
strategy as a small self-attention layer
and then to optimize these weights of
the self-attention layer to essentially
perform better black box optimization
and again here we can use a simple pmap
across different Evolution strategy
parameters and a vmap across multiple
evaluations of that specific Evolution
strategy
and it turns out that self-attention is
a really good and nice inductive bias
for parameterizing evolutionary
optimization algorithms because without
a positional encoding and self-attention
essentially gives us a set operation
that if you change the ordering of the
inputs also The Ordering of the output
is going to change accordingly and this
is a useful property for evolutionary
optimization
and we have some results showing that
this discovered or meta-optimized
Evolution strategy beats many or
exhaustively the baselines on these Brax
continuous control tasks I showed you
before
the second application is to use the
same sort of framework of using
evolution in the outer loop to do meta
optimization in the context of genetic
algorithms which use some form of
selection and mutation rate operation
and again parametrize them with the
tension and obtain better or learned
discover genetic algorithm
okay and again we perform outperform
baselines and are happy about that
good so now let me come back or someone
close out when I wanted to talk to you
about today
um so some of you might know this sort
of survivorship bias fallacy or I think
nothing Talib and many of these Popular
Science people have written about this
which is literally about the question
what to reinforce in in science or what
direction or what to reinforce in
engineering and the base example is
um this airplane from the second world
war which basically returned after
afterward home and had all these
different sort of bullet holes through
it and the engineers afterwards wondered
what part of this plane to to reinforce
going forward
and one thing to keep in mind is this
plane has returned home right so
basically all the people who sat in that
plane have swived okay so this is a
successful airplane but oftentimes
um
we then would intuitively go ahead and
reinforce sort of the the things where
the bullet holes were in and what I'm
trying to argue is that this is
basically sort of similar to how many of
our
um sort of heuristics or empirically
um well-served uh Tools in deep learning
come about right so things like skip
connections or a pre versus post-layer
Norm using layer Norm at all
um using gated cells in in recurrent
neural networks using uh the famous
capacity constant these are all things
where we're trying to duct tape things
that don't work about gradient descent
while potentially Evolution might allow
us to discover new components which can
circumvent this and to really drive home
um yeah what's actually working about
the gradient based paradigm okay and
this sort of relates to a recent paper
or a paper from 2021 by Sarah Hoka which
was termed the hardware Lottery where
she basically highlights how many of the
tools that we use right now came into
fruition because
um at the point of In Time the hardware
stack as well as the software stack sort
of really enabled them okay so if you
think about the the imagenet moment in
that imagenet moment
when krishowski and Hinton And subscribe
sort of came up with alexnet there was
basically a two things came together we
had
deep neural networks sort of somewhat in
place confidence and in the other
setting we had Nvidia gpus and Cuda and
could really bring these two things
together
and to me Jax is somewhat giving us a
similar opportunity in the context of
evolutionary optimization and sort of
discovering or looking at what other
paradigms might support or help grading
based optimization going forward
okay so we're now here
um I hope you're as excited as I am
um if you want to check out the code it
lives in in my GitHub robot
evosacs there's a paper now on Evo
snacks accepted at Gecko this year and
yeah with this I want to end and thank
you all for your attention
[Applause]
thank you so much for this fascinating
talk I I personally learned a lot of
things thank you and there are many many
questions we might not be able to answer
all of them so I guess you have to stick
around for a moment longer I can do that
but nevertheless let's try what are the
best resources to get started with Jax
using evosex
um so there are amazing blog posts for
Pure Jacks I believe there was a
previous talk at this conference by our
own moderator who spoke about how to get
started with Jax and um in general I
would say even though like Google a big
corporate company is is maintaining it
mainly
um there are a lot of very helpful
people who are trying to
um yeah scale this or have it be the
future of automatic differentiation and
distributed computing so um I've written
a blog post as well there are many
notebooks to get started and for evosacs
basically there is
um
in the repo there are many example
notebooks for example here which run to
the core API running this on some
continuous control tasks and showing you
how to use the API
currently most upvoted question is
relating to the limitation you pointed
out up until 1 million parameters but
what happens after 1 million plus that's
a really good question so um
it's just no longer competitive with
green descent based tasks right but this
is also something or great in the
sentence optimizers something where
um there might not or it might not be
the best setting to compare against
Green descent based optimization because
evolutionary optimization allows to do a
lot more and it's more General but might
not be best targeted at trying to
optimize slash language models okay if
you try to fit in like 1024
um chat GPT sized models into memory
yeah good luck okay so
um this is basically where what I would
say like you run out of memory and you
might no longer be as efficient in terms
of doing the optimization that you're
trying to do
so regarding your package development
what is the roadmap for evosex and how
can somebody help contribute to the
library
um yeah thank you very much that's a
great question
um so first of all like everyone who's
working with evil sex or has tried
working with it it would be great just
to get more feedback and to see sort of
what kind of problems might arise in
certain settings and going forward
I'm going to try to to
add more features to make it scale
better so for example right now most of
these strategies themselves as a single
strategy they run on a single
accelerator but you could for example
also try to parallelize
The evolutionary optimization similar to
how optax allows you to do a data
parallel or
model parallelism across different
devices so that's something I'm
currently working on and making evil sex
maybe a bit closer to to how uptax Works
in in the setting of creating
design-based optimization
regarding your choice of Jax
are there any fundamental limitations of
Pi torch that prevent you from
implementing the algorithms in a similar
way or is it just that vmap is an
awesome feature
um also a good question so
um I'm not here in the role of an
evangelist okay I'm not here trying to
try to convert everyone to use Jacks
okay I think many of the or checks and
pytorch have converged to similar
capabilities right especially with touch
2.0 you have just in time compilation
and
um
some of the features which Jax provides
um but basically when I started working
on this torch didn't have them and if
you wanted to batch certain things up or
vectorize them you had to do sort of all
of the math with the dimensions in your
head and that was something I wasn't
really happy about furthermore Jax
allows you to more naturally sort of run
things on TPU and
yeah I think it's just like a really
well clean functionally designed
programming language while with pytorch
it can sometimes feel a bit like it was
more added on top but this is my
personal sort of perspective on this
what about stopping criteria are there
any ways to estimate convergence uh yeah
so actually there are a couple of things
implemented like for example
um we have some strategies like bipops
CMEs and hypop CMAs which adapts sort of
the population size on the go based on
stopping criteria and looking at how
Fitness is improve or do not improve
across time and there are a couple of
these implemented I would have to dig
out where they are right now in the
strategy but um yeah like most of the
times they are either related to how the
fitness changes over Generations or how
the standard deviation of the search
distribution has converged
then I would like to thank you once more
for a fascinating talk and I'm afraid we
have to come to an end soon but
you'll be um right and yeah okay thanks
thank you very much
foreign